hey guys can I help you there are
certain networks that we see as harmful
to our families and we want them removed
please oh you don't want cable anymore
no no just ID network A&E oxygen and
Oprah network all the ones with murder
point you don't like paying for all the
channels oh our company actually
packages channels together can you
unpackage them so we only get the
channels we want oh I'm sorry our
company doesn't work that way dang it
guess you have to deal with our
packages hi is there a problem here
you mean that we're forced to pay for
the Oprah Channel I guess if you don't
want to be forced to pay for Oprah you'd
have to shut off your cable Al together
hey Mitch when can you get out to shut
off some cable boxes oh man it's going
to be like three weeks there's a whole
plug I have to pull out it's like 4 in
long maybe I missed something with the
younger people and the nipple thing
something something I'm not going to rub
my nipples right now is that it